Ron desantis's polls have been on the
decline and his share is in the
prediction Market have declined around
30 plus percent over the past 30 days I
believe that Ron DeSantis is an
excellent uh political leader in many
many ways and what we've been seeing
over the past 30 days has been very very
bad for him which requires a course
correction I'm a fan I'm a fan but his
his his campaigns failures and the
people who surround him have been so bad
I question whether or not he's actually
fit let me show you this one predicted
and we'll talk about what's going on
with us and DeSantis and the the desire
I guess from descended supporters for
there to be drama and for the tends to
lose support
so overpredicted you can take a look at
basically how this works is you can buy
a share of a candidate they're called
contracts and um who do you think is
going to win Donald Trump is at 56 cents
that means if you buy yes and he becomes
the nominee your that share is worth one
dollar so you'll make you know 44 cents
Rhonda Santos is at 23 cents and he's
declined quite a bit when you take a
look at the 30-day chart here for
DeSantis he was actually he peaked in
June on June 9th 35 cents and he's
dropped down now to 22 cents so it is
going down Vivek ramaswamy is popping up
this is the the example I want to give
to say this to the status campaign you
guys need to listen to the criticism and
course correct because right now what I
see is the Santa supporters are so
fervent and they're behaving very much
like Democrats to the point that if
Ronda Sanders makes a mistake and
everyone's surrounding him just says
he's right no matter what he will lose
support and that is what's happening
which brings me to the story that
happened just a few hours ago let's talk
about the Santa's campaign many of you
may be familiar with a video that went
viral where chanters in New York were
saying were coming for your children
many of you are probably aware and some
of you may not be that that was filmed
by alad aliyahu our field reporter who
was specifically contracted to film for
Tim Cass news that footage is property
copyright owned and licensed out by
timcast news to uh for for use a lot of
people have used it without permission
and there are questions about whether or
not they should have done that that
ultimately Falls to illad aliyahu who
retains the rights for it for licensing
outside of timcast to certain degrees we
have we have an arrangement with him so
it's going to come down to whether or
not uh he he's he believes that we have
to pursue these things the Rhonda
Sanders campaign took the the video nine
seconds of it
wrote paid for by The Descent of
DeSantis for president and started
texting it out to people
it's not an ad it's literally just the
clip that from from our Twitter that we
published and we own I did not go to
them screaming like I did I did speak
with people who associated with the
distance campaign
um the first thing I did before any
communication happened is I get hit up
by a bunch of people saying did you sell
this footage of the status campaign
because I'm seeing this thing and I said
no we didn't I then have to talk to elad
because we have an arrangement where he
gets he he gets uh uh he gets paid
essentially a percentage based on
licensing we want him to make as much
money as possible when he produces these
things we want to promote him and
support his work so he gets that money
not us
if someone comes to me and says hey dude
you like I'm not saying this would
happen but this is what we you all need
to consider someone comes to me and says
hey I'm supposed to get paid when you
license this footage out this thing says
paid for by DeSantis for president did
you sell that footage and not tell me
because you'd owe me money if that was
the case I'm more proactive on that so I
said hey hey guys no like we didn't do
this what do I do I tweet we did not
license this footage to Rhonda Sanchez's
campaign all I tweeted that's it I did
not say how dare they they stole from me
who they owe me all this money I said we
didn't listen to them then people start
attacking me saying you're stupid you're
a people who write for various
conservative websites high profile
individuals and lawyers and millions of
followers people associated with Rhonda
Santos's campaign saying I was stupid I
was a more I was an idiot it's not how
it works how stupid is Tim Paul Etc et
cetera these are not random people these
are high profile personality support
DeSantis and I'm sitting here confused
like yo all I said was we we didn't
license to them and so I tweet again I'm
like people aren't getting it they
tweeted out our video just just our
review nothing else saying paid for by
the test for president they're lying
they did not pay for this
and then people start claiming how dare
you they're saying that they paid for
the ad I'm like it's not an ad it's just
our video they're tweeting our video to
people and with with the tag on it paid
for by DeSantis there's no context
there's no statement there's nothing
added to it they wrote we're coming for
you for your children which is the quote
from the video with paid for by DeSantis
it doesn't say this is a commercial for
it stands for president we're seeking
your approval here's a clip you should
watch nothing it's literally just our
video
all I said was they didn't pay for it
the the the the absurdity and the
insanity that I see here is for one you
tweeted me all day and night about how
I'm stupid or whatever I don't get the
point do you want me as the Santa
supporters to go on to my show and just
insult his campaign because all it does
is generate hatred and animosity between
someone who otherwise should be
supporting DeSantis
how about instead of screaming and
shrieking like banshees you simply just
say hey we're going to reach out to you
and um you know what what's your what is
your ask so I actually reached out
immediately after after like I'm getting
hit up by people who are like hey
they're using this footage without
without credit without attribution and
there's actually so like we have lawyers
there are questions about whether or not
a political campaign can fair use news
coverage without attribution and minor
things they cannot even they can't make
various claims I didn't I didn't attack
them I didn't scream I don't mind so I
was like I was like hey look man I got
people hitting me up asking me like if
we sold this to you because if we did
I'm gonna end up owing money to people
so I don't like that you guys are saying
paid for by DeSantis if it's just this
clip and they're like yeah no worries
man like we'll sort things out totally
fine but these people online is high
profile influencer support to Santa's it
seems like they're trying to burn his
campaign to the ground all they're doing
is trying to make like it's like you
were saying I guess Ian you know I would
agree with you to a certain extent it's
almost like they're Trump supporters
pretending to be designed supporters to
hurt his campaign
I would I tweeted that I would
ultimately believe it except some of the
people who have been coming at me in the
past literally do work for his campaign
so
all I can say is that that's where we're
at for now but the bigger picture here
outside of the personal context with us
is
these the the fervent zealotry and
supportive DeSantis is going to sink him
his polls are down his predicted Market
stuff is down yo if something happens
that makes a sentence looks look bad he
needs to be realistic and personable and
address it in an honest way and that's
how he wins but the course that they've
taken over the past 30 Days shows
exactly why the prediction Market is
showing a decline exactly why his polls
are dropping yeah did they at least use
a watermark on that no
there's a lot of questions about it um
some people are like Tim said he wants
everybody to have it the other day and
he didn't care and I'm like there's a
difference between my opinion of this
should be seen by everybody that's why
we do it and I have an arrangement with
a contractor who retains rights over
that footage outside of what we want the
footage to be that has to be answered
for but even then I'm like you know
we're gonna talk with a lot and see how
he wants to handle a lot of these things
I'm not here to pick fights with
everybody just insult them but
there is a legal precedent my
understanding right now just just for
clarity's sake for the people who are
saying it when you see political
campaigns and it shows like a clip of a
news anchor saying a thing they show the
title of the segment or the or the date
and the publication they they have to
attribute it when they do these things
right and uh they certainly did not the
other thing people need to consider uh
so I can explain fairies to you guys
news organizations are largely exempt
from claims in this in this manner there
is uh varying degrees of arguments on
fair use okay
if you
if you produce a a News segment as a
news Organization for the purpose of
monetization and licensing people can't
just take it and use it
however if it's embedded on Twitter you
can use that embed in your articles and
that's what people do you cannot
download the footage and re-upload it to
your organization and some organizations
that we like conservative ones have done
this and yes we have been in discussion
of we're going to request licensing fees
for that so you know it's it's it's like
how do we be reasonable people in
support of those who would spread around
news that we want them to spread but
also make sure that uh I'll put it
simply
if an independent reporter covered this
footage if elod was working by himself
and did not work for us he would have
made substantially more money
we cannot have a reporter work for us
who is in the end making less money it
makes no sense so as an independent
reporter he owned he has the license to
this he can go to anybody and say you
owe me X you owe me X you owe me
actually got to pay and he'll get it as
a large organization we front the costs
of the trip so that he reports under our
brand however
for what reason would he have to do that
if he's just going to say but then I
don't make any licensing fees no we
respond with we'll we'll let you retain
licensing fees and if we license it out
we'll we'll send that your way but we
get the effectively the brand
recognition so the important factor here
is it's not fair use when the footage is
produced specifically for the purpose of
Licensing and for news reporting there's
other arguments about if someone writes
an article or references things and
you're commenting on it directly totally
understand a degree and these things
have to be adjudicated a judge will
determine whether or not it was fierce
or not fair use is 100 always copyright
infringement it's just whether or not
you'll you'll fonder the exemption well
just just to be clear just my final
thoughts on this I am not saying my
demand is that DeSantis should have paid
me for this that is not what I'm saying
that maybe a large position all I'm
saying is people came to me and asked me
if we sold this to them because it says
on the video paid for by DeSantis I
understand people are saying political
ads reference that who it was paid for
legally and they're not saying that
video was paid for by him I am saying it
is creating confusion in the marketplace
and it's and so all I did was issue a
statement to clarify as I'm supposed to
do and I'm getting attacked by the Santa
supporters for it yeah and the
clarification's incredibly reasonable I
would say probably a lot of the backlash
is just people being completely ignorant
to the entire process of paying for
flights sending out a reporter or going
out there getting it all this stuff fair
use doesn't just mean somebody can spend
all that money and you can just cop it
and put it on your Cable News Network
without any credit at all without paying
anything like that I know you said it's
not about the money there but I think a
lot of people don't understand all that
goes into getting this footage and then
having it reasonably credited credited
as well I'm I'm personally not super
concerned about
um credit the money and stuff but that's
not my rights elad retains those rights
to a very large degree as per our
agreement with them which means
if he's seeing stuff he's produced be
sent far and wide
typically on his own when he reports he
sends an invoice like hey I own the
rights of this you got to pay for it now
he's he's operating under our Banner
that doesn't change thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time